who says this is a man's business
nothing on board would work without
stewardesses like Natasha Romanov she
helps ensure that everything in the
kitchen and dining room runs smoothly I
study cartel ink and hotel management
and I worked on portal in Poland very
sweet fresh
working straight through for four weeks
with no days off is a hard school but
everyone on board is in the same boat
there are no weekends or holidays on the
brave turn the 60 men are under time
pressure
the 80 windmills out in the North Sea
were supposed to be finished by now the
project is a 1.7 billion euro investment
wind and weather have frequently
interrupted work on the wind farm now
Lee kelo has to make every hour count
the last windmill is his responsibility
but the last nacelle the machine house
is still on the ship's deck not on the
windmill Tower Joe Joe he's a bag
falling in the cell his bag full of
water into the cell there's men 10 12
bubbles at least leak hello is the
lifting supervisor on deck if something
happens here he's responsible but he
takes part in the physical labor to just
preparing to lift at the cell now so
we're we're hooking the taglines onto
the crane so the creek controller during
the lift
just wait the times that we hooked
things on and hook things off the hook
just keep a record for the LCM just for
the daily report what time we left
someone off the deck what time we land
it after 12 exhausting hours on deck he
still has to do the paperwork in the
office his boss needs the report
immediately good people likely kelo are
hard to find the company recruits from
many different professions electrician a
good start also if it's not installation
it could be commissioning starting at
the turbine or the cable work will be
more flexible than but also we have a
lot of good back Smith's steel
construction workers
geography aku top ski working out in the
exercise room the assembly fitters need
physical strength piatra an officer is
here because he likes it he's here every
second day
you're feeling much better you feel fit
you feel much happy when you're sitting
in your cabin watching the movie every
day you are only getting much more fat
and you are not happy believe me on the
bridge stewardess Adriana's chest now is
cramming for a test to become a deckhand
she knows she's going to lose her job
like many crew members Fred Olsen
shipping is going to hire Filipinos at
lower wages but only the boss is
permitted to talk to us about this
in general everybody has a bottom line
for their operating costs it costs so
many thousand dollars a day to operate
this vessel and Fred Olsen will always
be looking for the best deal in the
market to hide the vessel out for a
competitive day rate so they can compete
with the other companies installing
offshore wind farms costs are a big
pressure on the shipping company
filipina see men are well-trained and
will also get responsible jobs on the
bridge piatra p aku tov ski is lucky his
contract is not temporary he'll be
keeping his job
you are growing up with your experience
so you can join to other vessels from
the beginning to the end you are always
liking an adventure this is part of the
job to a trip home by helicopter after
many weeks at sea leave to go home but
what about the last windmill it's still
not finished